por favor no más me ahogo fue el grito
de auxilio del abogado javier ordóñez
cuando dos agentes de la policía de
bogotá lo redujeron en el suelo y les
sometieron a incesantes descargas
eléctricas
con un arma tipo de ser durante más de
dos minutos fue trasladado a una unidad
policial y posteriormente a un centro
hospitalario donde murió
cd soy un ciudadano estaba alicoramiento
que estaba alterado que agredió a la
policía que ya había sido controlado y
que lo único que estaba pidiendo era que
no lo agredieran más que no lo atacaran
más con eso te hice le siguen y le
siguen y le siguen metiendo esa kaiser y
además se lo llevan a un cai no hay una
explicación clara y el ciudadano termina
falleciendo en un hospital dra
eso es inaceptable los hechos ocurrieron
durante la madrugada del miércoles según
testigos y el abogado padre de dos
menores replicó las autoridades cuando
éstas le impusieron un comparendo por la
ingesta de alcohol prohibido en el marco
de la pandemia la respuesta policial fue
aplicar la fuerza y el vídeo grabado por
los presentes rápidamente se viralizó
las imágenes desencadenaron una oleada
de protestas en las calles de la capital
y se replicaron en otras ciudades del
país el ministro de defensa prometió
justicia en el caso concreto de los
graves hechos ocurridos en el barrio
santa cecilia los dos agentes son ya
objeto de investigación disciplinario y
penal y la institución dará toda la
colaboración que refiere a la autoridad
competente el caso de ordóñez quedó en
manos de la justicia penal militar una
noche de manifestaciones y conmoción
pues las imágenes de la muerte del
colombiano recuerdan a las de georges
floyd afroamericano que murió en eeuu
luego de que un agente apoyara su
rodilla contra su cuello por casi nueve
minutos y por las que se desataron
masivas movilizaciones sociales en todo
el mundo contra la violencia policial